[Música]
con la importancia de ser y parecer
no fue abogado pero no parezca logar
pero recorrido
se manda gente no cree que puede jugar
y eso es por qué
nunca me ha visto como abogado
mi padre tenía una frase decía el hábito
no hace al monje pero lo distingue
ah me habría ustedes conoce al señor que
está en s
pero la mayoría está acostumbrado a ver
en esa imagen
en 1851
josette de vida cabañas
rechazó una medición de galicia
imagínese usted es lo que comento que
voy a sacar un papel
porque les quiero leer un fragmento de
lo que dijo cabañas cuando rechazó la
mención en primer lugar todos los
ciudadanos tenemos la estrecha
obligación de ser útiles a la patria y
defenderla cuando se ve amenazada de
algún peligro cuando hemos pedido
ocasiones de prestarle algún servicio
señalado no hemos hecho más que llenar
nuestro deber
cuando un cabañas rechazó la personita
que hicieron decían que lo hacía por
razones de índole política
que también lo hacían
porque no había suficiente dinero en las
arcas del estado
uno de los problemas que voy a hacer
algo
[Música]
uno de los problemas
de tener a cabañas en el billete digo yo
se lo tenemos muy cerca d
[Música]
y se nos olvida
y ese señor que estaba normalmente en
estatuas
es una figura y de nuestro esto ya se
coloca como imagen de la honradez se
coloca con mi imagen del servidor
público ejemplar de masas fue llamado el
soldado de la patria y uno de los
problemas de esta misión de esta hermosa
hermosa difuso dibujo del señor el que
fue publicado en 1857 en el libro
exploración de molduras de william webs
este nos aleja de la posibilidad de
creer que podemos ser como cabañas
se nos olvida se nos dice que es a costa
de un álbum de primaria eso nos habla de
él en una estatua y se nos olvida que su
ejemplo es perfectamente posible de
seguir
ese es el modelo con el cual nosotros
hemos crecido cómo llevar ese modelo a
la realidad cotidiana de eso vamos a
hablar próximos minutos
no sé cuando ustedes han tenido en su
mano una moneda de 2 centavos
yo les pido mi pan que me muestran un
billete de vendidas la mayoría para
demostrar pero si les pido como en las
piñatas que saquen una moneda centavo
posiblemente nadie la extras
esto es una manera del centauro
en 1999
yo era responsable del comisionado
nacional de los derechos humanos en san
pedro sula
y tenía varios empleados a mi cargo
tenía incluso la jurisdicción de esta
zona del litoral
yo tenía un joven empleado oscar natural
de la señora
además facebook del bingo bien
o sea hombre sufrido
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y había ingresado en el puesto más bajo
había llegado como vigilante pastor
mantenimiento ascendió el puesto y
terminó siendo educador de la
de la oficina buenísimo dedicado
estudioso de fuerte carácter y en alguna
ocasión lo mandamos a hacer una
actividad educativa en fuera de san
pedro sula
foster
regreso
y resulta que le rechace a una
liquidación
el alma será mérito américas piel había
quedado en la báscula
llegó junio son difícil
y me dijo por qué la rechaza las piezas
pero están las cuentas con todos aclara
las cuentas y yo mismo lo hice 2 pérez
realiza te hace falta 2 en ambos puestos
dos centavos y 2 centavos y dónde voy a
decir 2 centavos
yo no sé oscar es ingenioso inteligente
yo soy costaba resolverlos
al día siguiente en la mañana en la
mañana estaba molesto todavía en 2016
eso es un incidente 1999 hace 5 años
oscar me llamó por teléfono y me dijo
como estaba miguel quien piense que
intercambiamos saludos ver la familia y
el sentir yo le quiero agradecer la
atención intermedio en la dieta de pasos
a saber del incidente de los 2 centavos
a mí en la vida
se encargó de recordar
la cuestión de rechazo una liquidación
por los entonces pues tiene sentido soy
abogado
pero en las que yo siempre pongo este
ejemplo para decir a la gente que cuando
se rinden cuentas las cuentas tienen que
ser
las oportunidades
mostrar rectitud rendición de cuentas en
los momentos inesperados en el trabajo
en la casa por ejemplo en cualquier
situación cotidiana demás
ese es el valor del ejemplo siempre
pando
de una moneda de 2 centavos que apeló
precisamente de eso las cuentas tienen
estas caras
la mayoría de nosotros aceptamos que
hagan falta dos centavos porque ahora no
hay monedas pero eso no es excusa para
no dar cuentas claras
y eso es una gente
uno puede dar ejemplo como éste como
padre pero cuando uno
hace este tipo de enseñanzas todo se
puede encontrar sorpresas sorpresas a la
vuelta de la esquina siguiente por favor
como un paso en algunas oportunidades
cuando me manejan ustedes saben que hay
veces que uno va bien escartín y puede
doblar a la derecha en rojo dependiendo
del tráfico y señales capitales
y el semáforo en rojo
y entonces ir a la derecha no había
pasado ni diez metros para él de
escuchar la voz infantil atrás mío
de visita de seis años paula maría papá
de sastre en que el semáforo rojo
[Aplausos]
cuando el cuerpo de precaución
inmediatamente me di cuenta que es mi
casa
y me dijo mamá
rojo
no me quedó más que aceptar mi error de
más día me hizo cometer no lo va a
volver a hacer otra vez
cuando me ves yo seguía manejando me
dijo una sonrisa en el rostro
porque de eso se trata el ejemplo cuando
el ejemplo estado tienda de enseñanza
está bien dada a ir practicando
como lo hizo oscar como lo dijo una
pequeña paula marina de apenas 6 años de
edad
y es que cuando nosotros enseñamos algo
bien tiene que haber capacidad de que se
reproduzca y se repita esa conducta una
y otra vez lo que nosotros aprendemos en
nuestra casa desde chiquitos cuando
nuestro comando dice tonto
cuando llegamos a la casa y nos dice y
ese borrador de donde los en casas
a éste me lo regaló mayor magnitud y más
combates estelares
en las fosas
y nos olvidamos el poder de la palabra
la palabra y poderosa estábamos
escuchando a nuestro anterior es el
chimichurri
así se llama el café
es el gran tengo que decirte al chino y
surge porque es el gato de un amigo de
mi hermano y me dieron por favor se
llama chile
txingudi
tenía un tipo para que aparezca el texto
nosotros
hemos escuchado continuamente que
honduras está en el lugar 135 de 180
países en el índice internacional de
evolución del percepción de condiciones
que tenemos apenas 29 puntos de un total
de 100 muy lejos de nueva zelanda que
tiene 88 87 dinamarca
lo repiten lo repiten y nosotros los
vidiago y lo mandamos en facebook mira
como estado penal y repetitiva y
repetimos el punto tanto nos hemos
tenido la historia de que todos somos
corruptos y tormentas
eso nos olvide el poder de la palabra y
más tenemos a nuestros políticos y
dirigentes
rebatiendo esas afirmaciones
y le gustan 5 pies al gato saliendo de
tener 4
es buscarle tres pies a cargo sabiendo
que tener cuatro armas y de mazzini
churri pareciera que tuviera cinco pies
pues esa frase originalmente era así 5
pies al gato más o franceses todavía
dicen gustarle cinco pies al ternero
las frases cambios en algún momento ya
por el siglo 17 2 miguel de cervantes y
saavedra uso en botas de alonso quijano
testigos de expresión 310 al gasto
sabiendo que tienen cuatro para hacer
los huevos y con el tema del pie métrico
quienes son profesores de literatura
salen el primer oficial resulta que como
era tan popular la obra
gente empezó a aceptar eso como una
verdad al punto de que si yo digo una
reunión sin confianza al gasto sabiendo
que desde cuando todo es nueva
porque así no es la frase pues no era la
frase así y eso es lo que pasa como una
voz como autoridad una voz poderosa como
una voz de opinión pública importante
como seguramente lo fue el continente
cervantes saavedra
lo dice aunque lo ponga en boca de un
ojo
como don alonso quijano dijo y es que
tenemos que recordar que cuando nosotros
utilizamos nuestra palabra nuestra forma
de expresión nuestra autoridad para
repetirnos un concepto es el modelo s
esa réplica tan profundamente como lo
estamos haciendo en ningún documento que
pudieron hablar de mayor en vídeo a modo
verdad porque estaba haciendo a su
momento haciéndolos reír a ustedes
antes de empezarla
la exposición estaba pensando seriamente
ser ceiba
te digo para decir se impacten no
siempre en la escuela puede hacer
yo vivía mostrado porque siempre me
podían de español
[Música]
de mayo creció creyendo theron traidores
y eso es lo que ocurre cuando uno le va
recortando a la gente ideas en la cabeza
así que cuando yo le busco pies al gato
de busco cinco o le busco tres y
recuerdo en cualquier espacio donde esté
yo soy profesor en la universidad desde
hace 15 años tengo un programa de radio
mío me invitan opinar en los medios de
comunicación antes de venirme acá en la
radio de una radio
o bien para dónde va lo que está pasando
uno tiene la oportunidad de impedir en
los demás
y vean ustedes el mensaje también de
nuestros liderazgos nuestra dirigencia
de con respecto hacemos al ser
transparente pero parece el producto de
más estudios de comunicación permanente
7 nos cuentan casos terribles de
corrupción pareciera que en este país no
hay cosas buenas
a mí me gusta
contar esta historia con los cinco
nombres por favor
para el bien de nosotros
[Música]
la mayoría de nosotros conoce la
historia del ferrocarril que no se
construyó
conoce la historia del soborno bananero
las casas que no se terminaron el saqueo
del seguro social
los pasaportes que se ven de un corto
tiempo
cuántas veces más cuentan historias de
hombres promocionados
los factores las manos o bien la
historia de los cinco inflamables del 99
ese año una empresa transnacional quería
conseguir una contrata para los cultivos
de palma de abacá en la que se utiliza
para el engaño
símbolos diputados al congreso nacional
rechazaron sobornos se estarán
documentado los estudiantes
universitarios de ese tiempo premiaron a
estos diputados hay una mayoría quizás
más escuchados los hombres juan
valladares rodríguez padre de leo
valladares de ex comisionado francisco
salomón gimenez castro él va a ser
presidente de la corte suprema para que
medien alvarado de valdo cuellos el río
tomas casi nunca da
quiero que aparezca la foto
[Música]
s mi abuelo
verán que es a la losa llevar ese nombre
no es pesadísimo
cuando persiste oyendo las historias de
la abuela incorruptible de manuel
honrada
pero la historia no se famosa
afortunadamente lo mario arrieta y el
dogout ama fonseca paz descanse segundo
se encargaron de contar esa historia
además eran tan honrados que después de
ese incidente el gobierno los designó a
labores donde se requería ser honrados
valladares tomando de embajador el
congreso
alonso nano niveles castro en algún
momento se le designa presidente de la
corteidh y vuelve a ser vicepresidente
del banco central porque le encanta esta
historia porque tenemos que empezar a
rescatar utilizar esa palabra para
rescatar ejemplos nosotros conocemos
personas que hacen de él el servicio
público un apostolado conocer los
maestros que no faltan a la escuela
conocemos compañeros que dan las cuentas
ante dios donde están esas historias
que están en sus familias pueden
hacerlas a sus hijos
no tienen ustedes ideales
de la cara de mi hijo cuando uno cuenta
historias del abuelo del padre
porque yo crecí con un padre
[Música]
en alguna ocasión les tocaron estarlo
con partidos y se quedó cinco horas
esperando a que apareciera el hombre
al que le hago con las vías
acaba de verse
vamos a esperar que venga tenemos que
pagar por esos años detalles se va
forjando el carácter se va contando la
historia
y es que cuando nosotros vemos el amor
es importante resaltarlo hay conductas
honorables
pero nos dicen porque no se puede
hay mucha corrupción
y resulta que de tanto en tanto nos
llevamos algunos escritos hermosos en la
vida diaria que nos indica que puede ser
y vayan caminando por allí conmigo
miguel andrés
todos conocemos
palomitas con mantequilla
palomitas con caramelo por eso la
mantequilla pero para la vida que camina
y me dijo me agacho mire lo que mismo de
esa foto es mía
miren qué poco más hermosa
[Música]
son 5 hormigas cargando unas palomitas
de maíz
imagina que usted les tocará a cargar un
peso de aportación a la menta negocias y
la lanza pero una amiga debe ser una
carga portentosa no hay carga de tareas
y si te acometer si se hace en conjunto
colectivamente
es así como se cambia el curso de las
naciones es así como se cambia la
historia es así como se construye el
país que no tiene ustedes la hormiga que
acude hay una foto después de esa donde
esa única que ustedes ven abajo está
incorporada cargando no la posee
[Música]
se los cuento mi hijo dio besos yo me
acuerdo si nos tomamos una foto conmigo
estaba sorprendido era le dio así es en
la vida trabajo de equipo
determinación y es así como se construye
una nación transparente que lucha contra
la corrupción hay que ser marchando una
calle a veces hablando a los compañeros
a veces siendo el único que se emprendan
los demás se necesita determinación para
hacer y parecer
entonces quiero abrir porque está
esta charla no debe durar mucho espera
están cansados la pregunta es entonces
cuando se hace que después de pasar el
número 67 aparezca pasaron 6
[Música]
pasar el número 6 el 6 es un número
simbólico perfecto o una gran sicología
y nosotros sabemos y 7 se asemejan la
semana se descansa el séptimo día se
trabaja seis pero quiere enseñar
es mentira que se descansa
séptimo día realmente lo dedicamos a las
labores más nobles éticas y
transparentes de nuestra vida educar a
los hijos llevarlos a la iglesia
dedicarlo a las cosas espirituales abrir
a los amigos a divertirnos
y es así con la lucha por la
transparencia que la lucha contra la
producción es un trabajo de siete días a
la semana
52 semanas al año 24 horas 7 días no se
me ocurrió nada porque ponerles el pez
de abril ahí que no es el mercado pleno
ahorita porque si no o si es aire
hay que empezar de eso se trata hay que
ser perseverantes
en este trabajo o reunirnos toma tocar a
veces en la municipalidad otras veces de
la junta de agua
otras veces en el patronato
en el aula en la casa porque tenemos un
deber que cumplir yo tenía que vivir
encontrar una historia aquí hay unos
puntos suspensivos
yo trabajo en una organización holandesa
la sociedad holandesa tiene fama de ser
muy transfer
capitán hacer todo orden resulta que es
una institución con los botones de
servidor
es una organización creada por siete
partidos de distinta sello ideológico en
honduras se mete al logo de partida de
dios fortalece con capacidades de
liderazgos políticos y sociales pues
resulta que esta institución cuyo
destino está sellado a la historia de
don nelson mandela
me dio la oportunidad en una de sus
actividades de coordinar este hermoso
espacio que se llama escuela de
formación
gracias estos son muchachos de comayagua
muchacha de comayagua el paraíso listos
y estos son los muchachos de la
esperanza
ahí hay jóvenes jóvenes aspirantes a
líderes políticos de todos los partidos
eso fue el año pasado y les garantizó
que no se mataron visitar
no pudieron sentar a conversar dando un
ejemplo que a veces le falta a los
adultos ese espacio de escuela de
formación para la democracia es un
espacio donde nosotros enseñamos a los
líderes del presente del futuro cómo
planificar el territorio como construir
ciudadanía como planificar cómo
comunicar ese cambio
porque no le hice caso a la página
lo que sí es que los contactos que en
este primer módulo se diagnostican los
problemas del territorio en el segundo
módulo se dan herramientas para aprender
a escuchar
y dialogar en el tercero de herramientas
de planificación tienes cuarto se
trabaja
rendición de cuentas
transparencia
porque un horrible cuentas no es un buen
libro
finalmente luego los muchachos se
gradúan después de tres meses
yo no puedo garantizar que estos chicos
van a ser transparentes y no van a ser
incorruptibles lo que sí les puedo decir
es que nosotros hacemos el esfuerzo por
mostrarles las ventajas y desventajas de
no ser de esa manera
concluyó la charla de hoy
diciéndoles lo siguiente como no tiene
una fórmula yo solo dado siete pasos uno
tiene que buscar modelos tienen que dar
el ejemplo tiene que replicar que esas
prácticas tienen que comunicar las tiene
que
tarde valorado por las prácticas de
valores de propiedad uno tiene que ser
persistente y además de ser perseverante
esa imagen que ustedes ven ahí observan
todos le reconocen es una imagen de una
de mis películas favoritas los siete
samuráis
a la mayoría de ustedes quizás la puerta
de una versión más moderna o siete
magníficos' y los más jóvenes quizás se
acuerde de una todavía más moderna de
qué es
además insectos
acuerdan habías link que va a rescatar
un grupo de insectos buenos para nada o
dos
pues estos samuráis que habían perdido
su amor que vagaban libres
colabora con un pueblo capón frente a
los forajidos
y la historia trata sobre eso de que uno
tiene que enfrentar los problemas con
coraje y con determinación pues el
estudio de los amores dice que no hay
tarea imposible de enfrentar siempre que
se haga con fuerza como no con valor
recordando la visión del proyecto que no
quiere vivir le quedan las dificultades
y peligros siempre van a estar ahí
siempre van a haber voces que nos van a
decir que no se puede decir lo que no no
[Música]
lo que sí tenemos que hacer es recordar
como dice el código de los adorables
samuráis los problemas nunca van a
terminar siempre van a aparecer nuevos y
nuevos pero nosotros sabemos que cuando
la marea sube el barco también sube
[Aplausos]